ah oui c'est une bonne nouvelle
je suis très très content bon alors tu
as compris un temps que léonie pour
m'appeler tu demandes le téléphone
portatif numéro 17
c'est ça au revoir bon eh bien je crois
que je n'ai oublié personne
il est l'oncle archibald la tante léonie
le cousin persepolis
or il me semble pourtant que j'ai oublié
quelqu'un à bonjour à et bien et bien
c'est vous oui or c'est dommage je
voulais vous appeler en fait tant pis
voilà il y a une très très grande
nouvelle
ouais gel au téléphone
regardez il est beau évidemment il est
pas tout neuf mais il marche très très
bien
oui je les trouvais dans mon grenier et
c'est le facteur qui me l'a réparé tiens
mais c'est bizarre il n'y a personne ni
julie me françois ne sont là je ne
comprends pas parce que quand je le leur
ai téléphoné et bien et bien il n'était
pas malade
ils ne m'ont rien dit oh je suis inquiet
je verrai téléphoné à françois c'est que
la peine casimir je suis là à l'eau
françois passe c'est formidable je
t'entends comme si tu étais à côté de
moi c'est parce que je suis à côté de
toi tu es à côté pour ça alors c'est pas
gentil
qu'est ce que tu veux dire eh bien tu
viens ici exprès juste au moment où je
vais téléphoner qu'elles existent pour
m'empêcher de tap les émirs casimir je
t'en supplie je suis très fatigué je ne
pouvais pas me douter que les me
téléphoner encore une fois enfin le
téléphone n'est pas un jouet bon ok ce
que ça j'ai juste donné quelques coups
de téléphone à quelle heure ce maudit
appareils s'est il mis à fonctionner
bien le facteur est venu chez moi
juste après dîner il a fini de réparer
vers 10h et casimir tu peux me dire ce
qui s'est passé après 10 heures
alors que je venais juste de m'endormir
eh bien j'ai appelé tous les habitants
de l'île pour les informer de
l'existence d'un nouvel abonné et que
s'est il passé à minuit alors qu'il
m'avait fallu près de deux heures pour
arriver à me rendormir là alors à minuit
j'ai téléphoné à tous les gens que je
connais pour leur souhaiter une bonne
nuit
je sais je sais et je n'ai pas oublié et
que s'est-il passé ensuite à 3h30 à acro
heure et demie williams oui je rappeler
mes meilleurs amis parce que j'avais
pensé que je les avais peut-être
réveillé à minuit alors qu'elle fait eh
bien eh bien je les ai appelés pour
m'excuser de les avoir réveillé à 3h30
du matin
ouais bon et cooper il n'est jamais trop
tard pour s'excuser
si tu veux si tu veux mais que ce deal
passé ensuite à 6 heures du matin à six
heures du matin quoi il n'est pas très
agréable d'être réveillés par un ami
quand le soleil soleil quand le temps
est doux qu'il fait beau que les oiseaux
chantent
oui mais casimir si tu veux mais tu sais
quand on n'a pas dormi de la nuit
c'est beaucoup moins agréable que
d'habitude au bonjour julie oh là là ma
pauvre et très tu as l'air aussi épuisé
courage à toi aussi tu a réveillé tout
est prêt
julie il est beau hein mon téléphone je
ne l'avais pas plus encore les coûts de
casimir ne me parle plus de téléphone je
l'ait pas vu mais j'ai été réveillé
quatre fois par lui dans mon sommeil je
n'en peux plus a tout d'abord ça alors
mademoiselle ici l'abonné numéro 17
quoi encore passez-moi le kiosque que
s'il vous plaît
je suis né mais c'était juste pour
savoir si votre téléphone marche et bien
soit il faut faire quelque chose moi je
vais tomber malade si ça continue on
d'un côté la sema ton téléphone je vais
le mettre à côté de moi il vaut mieux
éviter les drames
écoutez je ne comprends rien ne vous
histoire
mais si c'est mon téléphone qui vous
ennuie eh bien je vais aller tout au
fond du jardin très bien excellente
l'idée que si le jean
mais ne nous at elle pas toutes les cinq
minutes bon écoute et je vous promets
que je viendrai vous prévenir avant que
vous appelez à tout à l'heure
il est quand même dire cette petite à
oui mais alors moi cette nuit j'ai cru
mourir avec ses coups de téléphone
tudoret julie jet soir se reposera un
peu à tout à l'heure
bonjour mon cher ami
ça n'a pas la dalle est trop mal un peu
fatigué mais ça va quand même un peu
fatigué seulement on voit qu'on avait
fait un sommeil aussi délicat que le
mille
mais je suis littéralement exténué le
site us 9
pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas rester couché
en magie et songer jeu là vous mais
j'avais des gens très importants
rencontrés et puis je tenais à dire ma
façon de penser à votre casimir de
malheur il est au fond du jardin mais si
vous préférez les lits téléphonie on
nous parlait plus de téléphone vous en
prie je préfère traverser tout le jardin
elle le voit si les la barre ou est
d'accord monsieur 10,9
casimir et là bas là
ah non non donc je lui ai promis de le
prévenir avant de lui téléphoner je vais
y aller
françois je suis venu tu apprécies mieux
que j'avais casimir d'où viens-tu record
du fond du jardin
il n'y a pas rencontré monsieur 10,9 à
non à ben c'est que vous avez pris deux
chemins différents parce qu'il est allé
le voir il a trés sommeil ou si il a pas
l'air de bonne humeur à ses formidables
comme un sexe du veut dire je vous dire
que premièrement je me fiche que
monsieur du snowboard bonne ou de
mauvaise humeur et que puisqu'il est au
fond du jardin
je vais pouvoir lui téléphoner bon bah
écoute si tu veux casimir tient bien à
l'eau mademoiselle c casimir quoi mais
pourquoi est ce que vous dites toujours
mon corps bon je voudrais l'abonné
numéro 17
merci oui allô c'est casimir ah oui
c'est bien le téléphone de casimir mais
n'est pas là et ça vaut mieux pour lui
d'ailleurs si vous êtes de ses amis vous
aurez l'obligeance de lui dire que si je
le rencontre
je lui enfonce son museau d'un coup de
poing je vous salue monsieur casimir
que se passe-t-il tuer les raps oh ouais
c'est exactement ça
je viens de me téléphoner mais je
n'étais pas là
[Musique]